[Music]
one of the best ways to watch the film
is like alone on a crappy VHS or some
old DVD player and I both knew that we
wanted the film to feel like a
documentary we shot the film
chronologically we had waypoints but
we're guided by GPS so they could
navigate through the woods without being
kind of hindered by a crew we shadowed
them as they were moving through the
trees then I kept away from them as much
as possible and there would be a bicycle
flag so when they got into the general
area of their Waypoint that's on their
GPS they could see the fly so that's
when they were instructed to pitch a
tent this is where you're camping for
the night and we had introduced plastic
milk crates and inside would be
foodstuffs fresh batteries for the
cameras own for the film camera and then
there would be these old-school
film canisters and inside those little
plastic containers would be directing
those and they were all instructed to
not read each other's notes so we set up
this conflict but we allow them to
choose the time when they want to have
it the mandate was just a role on
everything the name of the scene in the
script the confessionals it was the
moment the film where it stopped to be a
project about the Blair Witch and
started being a chronicling of their
last days on earth we were directing the
actress like their conscious speaking to
them for Heather is like you're
responsible for this I say your goodbyes
turn the camera light on and point the
camera at your face but give us
everything you got she took the camera
and walked off by herself and just had
this monologue to end all monologue
there was a lot more snot but there were
rivers and rivers of snot we wanted to
track a balance between the performance
and not getting too distracted with the
snot flow but I remember like for seeing
that monologue and our jaws dropped I
think that was the moment where we were
like wow this really could work we don't
screw it up we knew was something
special and we kind of made this little
bit of film history
[Music]